Jimmy Kimmel goes off on Republicans
over their new Obamacare repeal and
replacement bill will Rand Paul vote for
it plus President Trump goes to the UN
we do a full analysis I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show okay so I
have a lot to say about Jimmy Kimmel's
monologue last night Jimmy Kimmel has
sort of become the face of the quote
unquote moral movement for socialized
medicine in the United States because
his son underwent a heart procedure over
a Children's Hospital of Los Angeles
I have a lot to say about this I want to
go through his monologue in some detail
today because I think that it is
indicative of where our healthcare
debate is that this is a serious piece
of the healthcare debate now I don't
think that it should be because I think
that we have a tendency in our politics
to identify people going through a
difficult time people having experienced
something with having expertise on that
particular topic and I don't think
that's actually correct I think the best
arguments need to be used not the best
emotional appeals but I'll get to all of
that in just a second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
the u.s. concealed-carry Association so
you'd hear this story a lot there's a
good guy with gun somebody breaks into
his house he has to shoot them and the
problem is you never hear what happens
after which is the depletion up and
arrest the guy half the time and the guy
ends up in the court system that's why
you need the u.s. CCA
right now they're giving away the 27
concealed carry and family defense guide
and it's 100% free in this guide you
will learn how to detect attackers
before they see you how to survive a
mass shooting the safest and most
dangerous places to sit in a restaurants
how to responsibly own and store it on
even if you have little kids and a whole
lot more it's 164 pages it comes to the
bonus audio version so you can listen to
it when you're in the car this
life-changing guy is a hundred percent
free and for a limited time you also get
a bonus home defense checklist which is
awesome you get all of this at defend my
family now.com defend my family now calm
again you SCCA does wonderful work
protecting you and your family in case
you have to pull the trigger and
preparing you for the eventualities of
having to pull the trigger and right now
they're giving away that guide 100% for
that concealed carry and family defense
guide 164 pages of knowledge you need to
have defend my family now calm
that's defend my family now come visit
right now and go get the guide okay so
and the big story today
the continued push the late-stage push
for Obamacare quote repeal and
replacement so first things first this
is not an Obamacare replacement or
repeal it is an Obamacare cutback that's
good you know that's a step in the right
direction I think that the Cassidy
Graham bill has a lot of flaws in it I
don't think that it's going to lower
premiums all that much but it does pare
away at the underlying structure of
Obamacare particularly the funding
mechanism which means that you're gonna
have a situation where state governments
are forced to relieve the regulations or
absorb the higher prices of insurance
and that's not a bad thing yesterday I
won through in some detail what exactly
the Cassidy Graham bill is so if you
missed it go back to yesterday's show
and listen to it so I don't have to
spend ten minutes explaining exactly
what's in the new version basically the
Republicans have to pass this thing by
September 30th or they run into a hard
deadline because the way that this works
is that under reconciliation rules all
bills have to be revenue neutral the
only way that you can tell whether a
bill is revenue neutral is if you've
already passed a budget the current
budget expires on some December 30th but
for purposes of evaluation it expires on
September 30th and that means that they
have to pass something in the next week
and a half so they're really trying to
ram this thing through quickly right now
and that means the Democrats are
starting to push back in pretty hard in
pretty hard measure now their main
points of pushback is that this is mean
and cruel and cuts coverage and
pre-existing conditions go away and all
the rest of it first thing to know about
pre-existing conditions when we say
insurance we'll be forced to cover
pre-existing conditions there are a
couple problems here number one
insurance costs skyrocket because
obviously you can't cover somebody who's
new conditions or conditions that
already exist without having to charge
them or the government more money and
number two if they don't increase the
insurance reimbursement rates to doctors
doctors stopped taking the insurance
altogether this is why I Medicare for
all Medicaid for all it really misses a
big key component here which is doctors
don't take Medicaid and Medicare and
increasing numbers because the
reimbursement rates are too low so all
the talk about pre-existing conditions
it's one of those things where it's the
government saying something that sounds
nice but it doesn't necessarily
accomplish what it's seeking to
accomplish it's like the South African
Constitution guaranteeing a right to
housing but nobody has a house right
here you can guarantee that people with
pre-existing conditions are covered but
coverage does not equal care coverage
does not equal care and it certainly
does not mean decreased cost for
everybody else that's why the Affordable
Care Act was so stupidly named it has
not made care more affordable in any way
shape or form so bill Cassidy if you
recall was the senator from Louisiana I
criticized him at the time he went on
Jimmy Kimmel show on ABC News and he
said that on ABC late night and he said
that he wanted to fulfill what he called
the Jimmy Kimmel test now the reason
that there was the quote-unquote Jimmy
Kimmel test is because Jimmy Kimmel has
a son and when the son was born they
detected a congenital heart abnormality
and they brought him to Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles where they
performed emergency open heart surgery
saved his life and presumably his son is
doing fine thank God all of which is
wonderful and demonstrates by the way
the flexibility and availability of
health care in the United States that
people can get immediate heart surgery
and by the way that's not restricted to
Jimmy Kimmel let's be clear about
something Children's Hospital of LA does
these kinds of surgeries on poor kids
all the time I know this because my wife
has rotated through Children's Hospital
of Los Angeles not only do I know that I
also know how good the care is there
because my daughter had open-heart
surgery at Children's Hospital of Los
Angeles in fact the same doctor Vaughn
Starnes who took care of Jimmy Kimmel's
kids took care of my kid so I've had
some experience with this as well Bill
Cassidy you'll recall the senator from
Louisiana appeared with Jimmy Kimmel and
on Jimmy Kimmel Kendall tried to define
what he wants the Jimmy Kimmel test as
everybody needs to be covered all the
time for everything
and Bill Cassidy sort of shied away from
that and now Kimmel is mad so first of
all Cassidy says look what we're doing
here is an attempt to is an attempt to
make health care more available and he's
right okay making healthcare more
available means that you have to have a
better market system it means you have
to have a better system where prices are
transparent where doctors are encouraged
to go into the market and compete for
the customer with the lowest available
price where quality goes up and price
goes down just like in every other
market and Bill Cassidy says this here's
what senator Cassidy had to say about
the notion that he wasn't fulfilling the
so-called kimmel test in your efforts to
do this again will it pass the Jimmy
Kimmel test absolutely there'll be more
people covered under the Graham Cassidy
Heller Johnson amendment then our under
status quo and we protect those with
pre-existing conditions
there'll be billions of dollars for
coverage for working families in states
like Maine Virginia Missouri Florida and
else
we're states that have been bypassed by
Obamacare but under Graham Cassidy
Heller jots and those folks will have
insurance so the way Cassidy originally
stated the quote-unquote Jimmy Kimmel
test was would the child born with a
congenital heart disease be able to get
everything she or he would need in that
first year of life even if they go over
a certain amount the problem of framing
it that way this is always Cassidy's
fault and Kimmel's fault the problem
with framing it that way is that you are
assuming that it is the government's job
to do all of these things or that the
government is best positioned to do all
of these things the government is not
best positioned to do all of these
things as I say there are a lot of
people on Medicaid who are not getting
the kind of care that they need
specifically because if you're on
Medicaid that doesn't mean that a doctor
is forced to take your Medicaid beyond
that the notion that Vaughan Starnes the
doctor who operated on Kimmel's Kevin
McKidd is sitting around rejecting poor
kids is just not true Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles
the hospital where Kimmel in that
hospital is a Charity Hospital that
means they've been endowments of
something like two hundred million
dollars people give enormous sums of
charity to Children's Hospital we give
some every year I know Jimmy Kimmel give
some every year that charity goes toward
helping these kids the idea that it's
the government's job to do this or that
it lowers healthcare costs in general by
doing this and makes it more available
is just not true
in fact many patients at c.h.l.i who are
getting these sorts of surgeries don't
have Medicaid at all a lot of them are
illegal immigrants again I know this
because my wife has worked at c.h.l.i
so you know this is my problem okay so
I've been kind of hitting Jimmy Kimmel
without letting him speak for himself so
here is Jimmy Kimmel and I want to go
through his monologue in some detail
here because I think that it is
important I think that we have fallen
into the trap of suggesting that because
we have sympathy for somebody's personal
situation we grant credence to a logic
that doesn't really work okay I'm not an
expert on health care or whatever
expertise I have on health care does not
arise because my daughter had a heart
surgery okay it arises because of the
fact that I've actually studied the
issues you know I'm it's because my wife
works as a doctor in this system it
knows the system intimately okay that's
where I get whatever expertise I have
the notion that we have in our society
is so stupid now that if you are if you
are the victim of something that makes
you an expert on that issue right if
you're a victim of terror now you're a
terrorism expert that's not the way that
it works in fact in medicine is
precisely the reverse if you're a doctor
and you're told to operate on your child
you're supposed to not operate on your
child because the idea
it actually distracts you from being
able to concentrate on the issue at hand
but because of the merger of
entertainment and politics we've
basically said that those whose hearts
are the fullest we're just going to
grant that their brains are also the
fullest I don't think that that's
necessarily true in any case here is
Jimmy Kimmel going after Bill Cassidy
last night with alacrity few months ago
after my son had open-heart surgery
which was something I spoke about on the
air a politician a senator named Bill
Cassidy from Louisiana was on my show
and he wasn't very honest it seemed like
he was being honest he got a lot of
credit and attention for coming off like
a rare reasonable voice in the
Republican Party when it came to health
care for coming up with something he
called I didn't name it this he named it
this he the Jimmy Kimmel test which was
in a nutshell no family should be denied
medical care emergency or otherwise
because they can't afford it he agreed
to that he said he would only support a
health care bill that made sure a child
like mine would get the health coverage
he needs no matter how much money his
parents make for one second so first of
all that test is not fulfilled by
Obamacare okay the test that everyone
can get coverage no matter if they can
afford it or not is not fulfilled by
Obamacare in fact it's not fulfilled by
any system there is no system on planet
earth but it fulfills the notion that
you get care for anything that you need
at any time regardless of cost this
system does not exist it doesn't exist
in France where they have rationing and
serious debt problems it doesn't exist
in Japan where they're increasingly
facing rationing and serious debt
problems it doesn't exist in Canada it
doesn't exist in the UK it doesn't exist
anywhere the systems where it does exist
the best places like Switzerland our
places where they mandate you spend a
significant percentage of your income
from the time you are very young on
health insurance and you buy it right
the government picks up the slack but
you buy it in the initial instance and
the truth is that even in systems that
tend to work you know somewhat decently
look Australia what you basically have
is a baseline basic health care system
and then it is on you to purchase the
over-the-top health care system and so
it's on you to purchase the
comprehensive health care insurance that
Kimmel was talking about so what he's
talking about this test it doesn't
really work in real life because there
is no such thing as a system that takes
care of everybody for free it just
doesn't you're gonna have to actually
spend enormous sums of money or you're
going to have to ration care there's the
only way
to do this and this has been true in
every system ever okay it's not a rip on
Kimmel it's just a rip on his logic cuz
his logic here is not correct okay he
continues have annual or lifetime caps
these insurance companies they want caps
to limit how much they can pay out so
our current plan protects Americans from
these caps and prevents insurance
providers from jacking up the rates for
people who have pre-existing conditions
of all types and Senator Cassidy said
his plan would do that too he's making a
couple of statements here the lifetime
caps and then he's making a statement
about jacking up the rates for people
with pre-existing conditions first of
all again just because you have a
pre-existing condition and you have a
crappy health insurance program does not
mean a doctor is necessarily going to
take that program number two how about
all the other people okay the vast
majority of people who get insurance do
not have pre-existing conditions those
people are being forced to pay through
the nose and a lot of them are opting
not to buy insurance which means what do
they do they wait until they do get a
pre-existing condition then they buy
insurance which banks are up the hello
woods which bankrupt the health
insurance companies and drives up the
cost of medical care okay so what he's
talking about again all of these things
sound great you know the insurance
companies they they want to put lifetime
caps these are options okay you can buy
an insurance program with no lifetime
cap in fact a huge number of people
throughout the United States who have
employer-based health insurance where
your employer buys your health insurance
like 90% of people who have health
insurance have employer-based health
insurance those people the vast majority
of them probably don't even have a
lifetime cap the vast majority of them
probably have no cap because they're
buying group insurance negotiated by
your employer again fact and
sloganeering are not quite the same
thing here at Jimmy Kimmel continues
said all this on television many times
so last week Bill Cassidy and Senator
limited Lindsey Graham proposed a new
bill the Graham Cassidy bill and this
new bill actually does pass the jimmy
kimmel test but a different Jimmy Kimmel
test with this one your child with a
pre-existing condition will get the care
he needs if and only if his father is
Jimmy Kimmel otherwise you might be
screwed now I don't know okay so again
there's that joke there utterly untrue
utterly untrue Vaughn Starnes performs
hundreds of surgeries a year
okay hundreds of them the idea that
their own they're all Jimmy come I'm not
as rich as Jimmy Kimmel thank god I do
well but I'm not as wealthy as Jimmy Kim
is and when I was when I was you know
getting my daughter surgery my health
insurance provider was provided by at
that time Salem which is the corporation
where I used to have a radio show okay
at that time I wasn't making nearly the
amounts of money that I'm making now but
we still got the surgery and again there
are plenty of people who are getting
charity surgeries from Vaughn Starnes at
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles go
and ask him it is a fact okay so this
idea that all these people are being
left out in the cold because of Bill
Cassidy is just not true and again
Obamacare doesn't fulfill the basic
preconditions that Jimmy Kimmel was
talking about right now he does not get
his health insurance through Obamacare
Jimmy Kimmel gets his health insurance
through ABC hey Jimmy Kimmel does not
have any problems here and by the way
neither does anyone else who works at
ABC because they get their health
insurance through ABC virtually
everybody in the United States who has
health insurance is not buying in the
individual market if you're talking
about in the individual market you must
have choice to bring down cost and
increase quality end of story you're
gonna continue with this because again I
don't like the emotional appeal and I'll
discuss the emotional appeal a little
bit more in one second but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
Birch gold so right now you're looking
at the possibility of a stock market
that may be overvalued you're looking at
a real estate bubble I think in places
like California you're looking at a
rather uncertain foreign field and that
means that you should have at least some
of your money in precious metals I'm not
saying that you should liquidate all
your stock and buy gold I am saying you
should have some of your money in a hard
asset that generally has value and has
always had value throughout human
history yeah that's why you need to talk
to my friends over at Birch gold group
they'll send you a comprehensive 16 page
free kit revealing how gold and silver
can protect your savings how you can
legally move your IRA or 401k out of
risky stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA to get your note
cost no obligation kit go to
birchgold.com slash pen that's www.h
goal.com slash pen again five star
ratings A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau the people I trust for
investment in precious metals
birchgold.com
slash been trustworthy folks go check
them out okay so let's continue with
Jimmy Kimmel and the analysis here
because it really is a maddening thing
to me but so many people in American
political discourse are interested in
playing this game where sympathy
overrides logic here is Jimmy Kimmel
continuing along these lines you might
be screwed now I don't know what
happened to Bill Cassidy
but when he was on this publicity tour
he listed his demands for a healthcare
bill very clearly these were his words
he said he wants coverage for all no
discrimination based on pre-existing
conditions lower premiums for middle
class families and no lifetime caps and
guess what the new bill does none of
those things coverage for all no fact
it'll kick about 30 million Americans
off insurance pre-existing conditions
note if the bill passes individual
states can let insurance companies
charge you more if you have a
pre-existing condition you'll find that
little loophole later so Cassidy
disagrees with this he suggests that
states in order to opt-out have to show
that they have affordable options for
people with pre-existing conditions as
far as universality Obamacare doesn't
create universality there are millions
of people who opted out of buying health
insurance on under Obamacare so
Obamacare doesn't fulfill really either
of these first two either and Cassidy is
saying that with more options people
will be able to buy coverage for
pre-existing conditions which by the way
is truly a you know there are groups
group insurance programs in the
individual market people have church
associations where they go and they buy
with their entire church health
insurance this stuff does exist
okay Kimmel continues after it says they
can't they can and they will
well will it lower premiums well in fact
for lots of people the bill will result
in higher premiums and as far as no
lifetime caps go the states can decide
on that too which means there will be
lifetime cats in many states so okay so
the idea of lifetime caps states can opt
not to opt out of Obamacare they can
Massachusetts will still keep that that
law with regard to no lifetime caps and
when he talks about affordability this
has been the big problem with Obamacare
it's driven up the cost of insurance so
Obamacare doesn't fulfill any of these
preconditions either but the idea that
more market options is a problem it's
because Jimmy Kimmel has a very
simplistic view of what health insurance
is supposed to be the government is
supposed to cover everything and all the
problems are supposed to go away that
doesn't exist anywhere on earth anywhere
in history nor will it exist anywhere in
the future that's not how health care
works
that's not how health care works as I've
said many times there are three elements
to health care universality everyone has
it affordability it's very affordable
quality the quality is very good you can
have two of these three you cannot have
all three most government-run systems
have unit
personality and an affordability to the
to the individual but not affordability
to the country and the quality kind of
sucks because they have to ration there
are some countries that have
universality and quality but not
affordability like Switzerland where
you're paying a lot of money out of
pocket to make sure that your insurance
is covered America has quality and
affordability but not universality I
want to say affordability I'm not
talking about the fact that on a per
capita level we spend a lot of money
that's true because we opt for a lot
more surgeries than people do abroad our
appa we have a lot more administrative
hurdles than people do abroad the
collective bargaining against the
insurance companies is not as strong
here as it is abroad because the
government basically crams down pricing
but that's because they have rationing
it turns out that if you're rationing
care it's cheaper than if you don't
ration care and people get to spend
whatever kind of money they want on a
particular surgery I mean you get to
walk in and demands and x-ray of your
doctor this does not exist in a lot of
socialized medicine countries it has to
be mandated from the top down by the
government okay so Kimmel continues any
state so not only did Bill Cassidy fail
the Jimmy Kimmel test he failed the bill
Cassidy test he failed his own test and
you don't see that happen very much this
bill he came up with is actually worse
than the one that thank God
Republicans like susan collins and lisa
murkowski and john mccain torpedoed over
the summer and i hope they have the
courage and good sense to do that again
with this one because these other guys
who claim they want Americans to have
better health care even though eight
years ago they don't want to anyone have
health care at all they're trying to
sneak this scam of a Billy cooked up in
without an analysis from the bipartisan
congressional budget office they don't
even want you to see it they're having
one hearing the hearings I read the
hearings being held the Homeland
Security Committee which has nothing to
do with health care and the chairman
agreed to allow two witnesses bill
Cassidy and Lindsey Graham to speak so
listen health care is complicated it's
boring I don't want to talk about it the
details are confusing and that's what
these guys are relying on they're
counting on you to be so overwhelmed
with all the information you just trust
them to take care of you but they're not
taking care of you they're taking care
of the people who give the money like
insurance complicated so that they're
taking care of the people who take care
of them like insurance companies
insurance companies donated tens of
millions of dollars to Obama's campaign
in 2008 and 2012
okay the insurance companies are been
getting huge bailouts from the federal
government on a regular basis under
Obamacare Obamacare
was federal government money going to
all these insurance companies to pay
them off for covering the pre-existing
conditions and as far as Jimmy Kimmel
complaining about the process I agreed
there by the way I grew Jimmy Kimmel the
process should be open the process
should be clear it should be transparent
it should also have been clear and
transparent when Obama was doing it so
that's not what about ISM that's
consistency it should've been clear and
transparent what Obama did it it should
be clear and transparent now under Trump
care okay finally Jimmy Kimmel ends up
reading the phone number of Bill Cassidy
and urging people to call there again
the son late-night TV right I mean this
is this is a political diatribe in the
middle of late-night TV Jimmy Kimmel can
do what he wants right I mean that's his
prerogative but in the end what he ends
up saying is that he acknowledges that
he's exploiting his son situation in
order to push a certain political
viewpoint and then he justifies that by
saying it has to be done we're all just
looking at our Instagram accounts and
liking things while they're voting on
whether people can afford to keep their
children alive or not most of the
Congress people who vote on this bill
probably won't even read it and they
want us to do the same
I want us to treat it like an iTunes
service agreement and this guy bill
Cassidy just lied right to my face and I
never imagined I would get involved in
something like this is not my area of
expertise my area of expertise is eating
pizza and that's really about it but we
can't let him do this to our children
our senior citizens and our veterans and
or to any of us and by the way before
you post the nasty Facebook message
saying I'm politicizing my son's health
problems I want to know
I am politicizing my son's health
problems because I have to we don't have
to worry about this but other people do
so you can shove your disgusting
comments where your doctor won't be
giving you a prostate exam once they
take your healthcare benefits away it's
true it's unbelief and England and
Canada Germany France they all figured
healthcare out and don't say they have
terrible health care because it's just
not true this is a bad bill but don't
take my word for it here are just some
of the organizations that oppose this
grandpa I mean this is it's like an
eight-minute PSA here and then he talks
about all of these various such all
these various organizations that would
make money under a socialized healthcare
system and when when when Kimmel says
things like France Germany Japan he
lists off all these countries again if
you actually look at the specifics in
each of these countries it involves a
combination
of rationing or massive debt massive tax
increases okay there are trade-offs in
health care just like in every other
policy public policy area and when he
says take your politicization
accusations and shove them up your butt
yeah again I haven't I've talked about
health care for years on this program
how many times have I suggested that I
get my authority for discussing that on
the basis of my daughter having an
open-heart surgery from the same doctor
at the same hospital as Jimmy Kimmel how
many times the answer is zero the only
time I've ever mentioned that on the
program is with regards to Jimmy Kimmel
invoking it and me saying listen you
can't invoke your kids health problem in
order to put in order to paint a
particular picture on health care these
that just doesn't hold and I do think
it's kind of egregious okay I'm not
somebody who thinks that it's worthwhile
exploiting the the issues your kids have
had me and thank God by the way just to
note my kid is totally fine she she had
a hole in her heart it was in atrial
septal defect in ASD and she they fixed
it she'll be good for life no problem
she operates just like any other normal
kid she has no lingering after fact
she's wonderful child thank God thank
God thank God thank you dr. Starnes
thank you to CH Li and thank you to my
insurance company for covering that but
I don't exploit that to talk about
insurance because I don't think personal
narrative is nearly as important as
making good public policy decisions and
I'm tired of this notion that like he
gets cheer he says I'm politicizing my
kids story because there's so many
others who can't well how about the
people who talk actually read the bills
how about the people who talk actually
like study this stuff it's so funny you
hear about the left they say well I'm
global warming listen to the experts
listen to the science listen to the
experts and then when it comes to stuff
like this they say screw that let's
listen to the guy whose kid had a health
problem hey it doesn't doesn't quite
work that way
doesn't quite work that way by the way I
think you should listen to experts in
all of these fields because I think
expertise matters I think people who
study things know more than people who
don't study things I think people who
know about economics know more than
people who know about pizza as Jimmy
Kimmel admits there
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna move on from
healthcare I promise after that I wanna
talk about from speech at the UN but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at helix sleep so helix
sleep is the best mattress you will ever
sleep on this is like a luxury mattress
that you get for the price of a
non-monetary mattress they have this
amazing thing where you go to helix
sleep calm slash pen and you take their
simple two to three minutes sleep quiz
asked to do you like to sleep on your
side your back your stomach what what
body type are you how much do you weigh
do you like the mattress to be
breathable do you like to be firm or
soft and then they use a proprietary
algorithm to create the most comfortable
mattress you have ever slept on if you
and your and your spouse have two
separate sides of the bed that you don't
enjoy sleeping the same way then you can
actually have a mattress that is created
that has two separate settings for each
side of the bed it is much less
expensive than the same exact mattress
that you'll get someplace else
Hewitt's makes it better okay so try it
and plus they have a completely
money-back guarantee try it for a
hundred nights and if you don't love it
they will pick it up and they will
refund you in full it comes in a box you
take it out of the box take it out of
the plastic and inflates right in front
of it's the easiest thing in the world
go to helix sleep calm slash been right
now you get 50 bucks toward your custom
mattress hulex sleep calm slash Ben
right now get $50 off toward your custom
mattress again helix sleep calm slash
Ben for $50 off your order and use that
slash Ben so they know that we sent you
okay so I'm putting a side jimmy kimmel
now and healthcare I want to talk a
little bit about president Trump's UN
speech because I think that there are
some interesting things that happened in
his in his speech yesterday I think
what's more interesting is the left's
reaction to the speech so let's be
straight about what president Trump's UN
speech was yesterday it was a basic down
the line george w bush foreign policy
speech with a little bit less
pie-in-the-sky about building democracy
that's basically what it was okay it was
well in line with the reagan bush
conservative hawkish foreign policy
consensus it was not a Ron Paul speech
he tried to use some Ron Paul language
and it created this kind of weird gap in
the speech where some of the language he
was using sounded like it straight out
of a bush speech and some of it sounded
like it was straight out of her on Paul
speech and it was much more of a Bush
speech than a Ron Paul speech I'll give
you an example so here is president
Trump yesterday at the UN talking about
what we expect of other countries this
is perfectly in line with basic Bush
Doctrine we do not expect diverse
countries to share the same cultures
traditions or even systems of government
but we do expect all nations to uphold
these two core sovereign duties to
respect the interests of their own
people and the rights of every other saw
Rijn nation ok so what he's saying there
is you know essential Bush Doctrine I
mean this is the idea that we expect
other nations to have standards for
their own citizenry and then he says
stuff like this here is President Trump
trying to merge that with the America
first language used on campaign trail as
president of the United States I will
always put America first just like you
as the leaders of your countries will
always and should always put your
country's first all responsible leaders
have an obligation to serve their own
citizens and the nation-state remains
the best vehicle for elevating the human
conditions that's a weird dichotomy
right there because he's saying in the
first clip he says as a nation as a
national leader you have an obligation
to your citizens to ensure interests of
your people and and freedom of your
people basically and then he says well
everybody has the interests of their own
nation and we're gonna leave you alone
and the nation-state remains the best
vehicle for elevating the human
condition I'm so weirded out by this
particular notion there are certain
nation states that do remain the America
remains the best vehicle for elevating
the human condition I don't think Saudi
Arabia remains the best vehicle for
elevating the human condition the
nation-state is an institution does not
necessarily represent the quote-unquote
best vehicle it is a vehicle but Nazi
Germany was a nation-state
I mean the idea that nation-states are
the be-all end-all it's kind of this
weird this is I've always had a problem
with the difference between patriotism
and nationalism I like patriotism
because it says that we defend the
principles on which America stands I'm
not as big on nationalism which says my
country right or wrong right I don't
think that anything right or wrong I
don't think my wife right or wrong okay
I just don't I don't believe in the idea
that you should side with things that
are wrong because they're things right
so I love America obviously but I love
America because of what she is if
America turned into a different country
overnight I wouldn't love America
anymore it's that easy right if America
turned into Nazi Germany I wouldn't love
it right is this very difficult this is
why I think that taking a value neutral
proposition like the nation-state and
trying to imbue it with value trying to
infuse value into a concept like the
nation-state which could be an evil
nation-state like the Japanese Empire
during World War two
or it could be a very good nation state
like the United States or Great Britain
right then that seems to me a very weird
notion and so you can see he's trying to
basically fit the square peg of American
exceptionalism and principle and creedal
values into this round hole of
nationalism generally and it doesn't
really work particularly well which is
why he ends up basically in the bush
position here is President Trump
sounding very much like President Bush
at the end of his speech at the UN
yesterday we need to defeat the enemies
of humanity and unlock the potential of
life itself
our hope is a word and world of proud
independent nations that embrace their
duties seek friendship respect others
and make common cause in the greatest
shared interest of all a future of
dignity and peace for the people of this
wonderful earth this is the true vision
of the United Nations the ancient wish
of every people and the deepest yearning
that lives inside every sacred soul now
what's amazing about that is that's
actually something that the bush used to
say that I disagreed with is this great
yearning for dignity and peace no no
actually that I don't think that's the
great yearning of the human soul is the
yearning for dignity and peace I think
there are lots of people throughout
history who have yearned for destruction
violence and bloodshed and victory right
I think that's the idea that if everyone
yearned for dignity and peace we'd all
be fine we wouldn't need a UN we don'twe
if you don't need a UN but we wouldn't
need we wouldn't need an army we
wouldn't need a navy wouldn't need an
air force if everybody yearned for
dignity and peace we'd all be fine
wouldn't we
but yeah again this is the awkwardness
of trying to of trying to merge you know
kind of traditional American foreign
policy with the isolationism that that
Trump I think sort of resonates to but
then when he gets down to situational
ethics when he gets down to Syria is
gassing its own people then he's like
fire a missile right and all that goes
right out the window and we're back to
to firing missiles in any case it's a
pretty traditional American speech on
foreign policy because it was
traditional because Trump over the last
couple of weeks has actually acted very
much like a traditional centrist
Democrat president
many ways because of all that that means
the media has to go ee nuts
so they try to find things to go crazy
over and it really is amusing actually
because what you see is the media now
defending Iran in North Korea from the
predations of President Trump
how dare president Trump rip on North
Korea and call kim jeong-hoon rocket man
right
and now rocket man's stuck in your head
again I know it's not my fault it's
Trump's fault I did like Nikki Haley's
defensive that line by the way she said
today that Trump it was great Trump used
Rocket Man cuz now everybody's talking
about Kim jong-un
listen I love the UN ambassador nikki
Haley I think she's doing a great job
but I'm pretty sure that everyone was
talking about the the fat little dude
threatening to nuke the United States
before he was called rocket man by
President Trump I think that has more to
do with Trump likes to nickname things
he's like the atom of nicknames God said
to Adam named all the animals God said
to Trump nickname all the people and
that's pretty much right in case the
media go completely insane over all of
this
ABC's Jim Moran he says that North Korea
you know when when Trump threatened to
new North Korea if they should attack us
you know how it starts terry moran who
has the same he has the same last name
is the insane congress person from from
up north in any case terry moran says
that this was a war crime he accuses
trump of war crimes in his UN speech
yesterday that is a potential
justification but the words totally
destroying a nation of 25 million people
that borders on the threat of committing
a war crime Wow borders on that threat
okay Bill Clinton said the same thing in
the 90s I got flak yesterday because
there was a headline that President
Obama had said that we could destroy
North Korea and people were saying well
he didn't say we would destroy North
Korea yeah neither did Trump yesterday
Trump said if they do something we will
then we'll destroy them right if they if
they fire a missile at us we'll destroy
them right Obama basically said the same
thing he said we could destroy them
anytime we want but we wouldn't want to
do that because because there are people
who are threatened okay so they're all
saying the same thing everybody knows
that if they fire a nuclear us will nuke
them right it's that simple
everybody knows this is the case but no
now it's a war crime the left is is
relegated to defending the worst States
on earth in order to rip president Trump
which is actually kind of humorous to me
I'm showing more of the press doing all
of that plus I have to do my Jerry Brown
impression coming up in a little while
but for that you're
have to go over to daily wired.com $9.99
a month gets you a subscription to daily
wire.com and you can be part of the team
that means that you get my show live
that means you get to be part of our
mailbag we did it we did something
called the conversation yesterday we're
only subscribers were allowed to ask
questions we're gonna do another one of
those with Andrew Clavin next month
we're in tune with Michael moles the
month after that as though he has any
answers to give but you can listen to
Michael Noel's to show that in 45
minutes you can also listen to Andrew
Clavin the show that's it or the
opposite and mixed up Andrew Clavin
shows in 45 minutes
Michael Knowles's show is at 12:30 today
Pacific time and you can be part of all
of our mail bags my mail bag is normally
on Friday we're gonna do that next week
because of a brochure Shana but
nonetheless you can do all of those
things for $9.99 a month for $99 a year
an annual subscription you get this the
very finest in all beverage vessels the
leftist tiers hot or cold mug famous
throughout the globe for its capacity to
hold liquid just unbelievable you get
that for $99 a year if you want to
listen later go to iTunes or SoundCloud
subscribe leave us a review it always
helps we appreciate also go over to our
YouTube page and subscribe there because
we put out funny little videos that
you're not gonna see at iTunes or
SoundCloud but you will if you subscribe
to our youtube page check that out we
are the largest and fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so more of the media losing
their minds
CNN's Jim Acosta who is not a reporter
he's a parody of a reporter Jim Acosta
it's like someone made a puppet of Jim
Acosta and put him on TV so Jim Acosta
is the guy who his whole is sole goal
now is to be in the White House press
room and then be shown on TV looking
indignant and now he is looking
indignant standing in the middle of New
York talking about the UN
I always find it humorous that the TV
channels feel the necessity to do this
like put a station and I like on a
random street corner in the middle of
New York to discuss these things like
they have studios I've been to CNN
studios in New York they're beautiful
but here he is in the middle of the
street yay
talking about how trump's UN speech made
everybody say OMG the president
certainly did not mince any words that's
right wolf in a senior administration
official tells CNN that that line about
Rocketman and Kim jong-un was added to
the President's speech this morning but
that was hardly the only provocative
moment as the president threatened to go
to war with North Korea with a speech
that made the UN GA say oMG what no
really
lmao OMFG LOL shrug e good reporting Sal
reporting from Jim Acosta I do you
appreciate Wolf Blitzer because wolf
blitzer's job is basically to be the
stupid third grader who asks questions
that everyone already sort of knows the
answers to but he asked to act like he
is the stand-in for the audience they
ask things like President Trump said
stuff Jim and then Jim gives his
explanation with with emojis and in my
memory so well done Jim Acosta it just
shows you where the media are MSNBC had
a guest on the guest name was Colonel
Lawrence Wilkerson and he launched into
the forum former Obama staffer of course
and he launched into president Trump
speech the worst speech anyone ever gave
my god my first reaction was he read it
from the teleprompter that means at
least HR McMaster and probably Jim
Madison John Kelly got a look at that
speech and I'm deeply saddened and
embarrassed by that fact that was the
most atrocious speech I've ever heard an
American president give in any venue
really
President Obama gave speeches at the UN
where he legitimately ripped our race
policies in the United States President
Obama went on a full-on apology toward
the beginning of his presidency where he
went to Islamic countries and talked
about how America was arrogant and evil
you know but again the media Trump is
force them into a bad situation they
hate Trump so much so in front does
something right they have to pretend
that he's doing something wrong
naturally we still have to trot out the
corpse of Hillary Clinton to talk about
how terrible
Trump is she's never gonna go away she's
just going to be the specter haunting
your home you're gonna be taking a bath
for one evening and then spookily she's
going to creep out of the mirror at you
and I hear as Hillary Clinton on with
Stephen Colbert all these late night
hosts are so in the tank it's it's
irritating like it's I get it but it's
super irritating here is Stephen Colbert
playing political pundit as always the
guy who made his name making fun of Bill
O'Reilly talking with Hillary Clinton or
the ghosts thereof about Trump speech
did you happen to see the President's
speech at the UN today I saw parts of it
yeah what what did you what did you make
of it I thought it was very dark
dangerous not the kind of message that
the leader of the greatest nation in the
world should be delivering you are both
you are both required to stand up for
the values of what we believe in
democracy and opportunity as a way to
demonstrate clearly the United States
remains the the beacon that we want it
to be okay this coming from the lady who
sends a message to the entire Arab world
and Muslim world in the middle of
Benghazi suggesting that our values of
the First Amendment were sort of a
problem because it allowed people to cut
videos that were not nice to Islam I do
have one question for Hillary Clinton is
she colorblind I who picked that who
picked that jacket I really feel like
I'm confused that anyone would think
this would look good on television first
of all there's a basic rule on TV do not
wear patterns second of all there's a
rule on TV do not wear the ugliest
jacket that you found at the Salvation
Army and Hillary Clinton apparently what
rubbage been hunting and found this
jacket and threw it on for for Stephen
Colbert's show but Hillary Clinton
lecturing us all on foreign policy after
presiding over the worst eight-year
foreign policy and recent recent memory
probably in history
it's pretty astonishing it's pretty
astonishing so there she is ripping
again this is the lady who was one of
the architects of the Iran zeal she was
working on it before she left the Obama
administration and now she's complaining
that Trump is too mean to places like
Iran yeah I can't imagine why the
Democrats remain unpopular meanwhile the
Democrats have decided it does go to
show you by the way all of this goes to
show you that all of the talk from
President Trump about making nice with
Democrats they will stab him in the face
at the first available opportunity now
in the back in the face he's a fool if
he thinks that he can work with these
people and they will then somehow be
loyal to him may President Trump is
currently trying to surrender on daca
the deferred action for childhood
arrivals program that's not stopping
Governor Jerry Brown 1,000 year old
Jerry Brown the governor of the state of
California from suggesting that Trump is
some sort of evil xenophobe who wants to
target illegal immigrants doesn't matter
the Trump just agreed with Pelosi and
Schumer on it doesn't matter no that
matter the only thing that matters is
that we know we know President Trump is
a bad man who hates brown people we also
know that my Walker needs a tennis ball
replaced because I keep scratching my
hardwood floors go Jerry Brown it
protects public safety but it also
protects hard-working people who
contributed a lot to California Part B
hard-working people who are undocumented
immigrants yeah by the way they've got a
couple million working our agricultural
industry our hospitality industry our
construction industry they'd be in deep
trouble without those same people and
that's why we need immigration reform
not blessed or not rhetoric and not this
kind of xenophobia that we see too much
of compete you understand we here in
California have invited every person on
earth to the state but we have no idea
why we have trillions of dollars in
unfunded liabilities the good news is
I'll be dead before any of that has to
be paid so there you are also oh okay so
then there your your wonderful Democrats
doing yeoman's work for the American
people
okay time for some things I like things
I hate and then I'll explain to you what
this weird new Jewish holiday is and why
I will not be here to provide you with
my stellar and incisive commentary
tomorrow or Friday so
time for some things I like so we've
been doing sort of gothic romances I did
weather in Heights yesterday and the day
before that I did Rebecca by Daphne du
Maurier this is there's a new production
of Jane Eyre I'd only have recommend
this on the show I have my Mathis so
this is actually a quite good version of
Jane Eyre this was not my favorite book
when I was in high school it annoyed the
living daylights out of me to be
completely Frank with you it seemed like
female wish-fulfillment but I reread it
recently it's pretty good book and the
movie itself is also quite good also I
am a huge Michael Fassbender fan I
cannot wait for the Snowman as I have
said a thousand times his new movie has
the worst trailer I have ever seen for
any movie in history we did a full seven
minute segment on the show on the
Snowman jr. is actually a good movie the
Snowman will be a terrible movie that I
will like more but here is the preview
for Jane Eyre with Mia Wasikowska is
that husband death and in Michael
Fassbender
do you know J now whether we care to go
after death they go to hell and what is
hell where are you right you don't still
you will be tied down pit full of fire
should you like to fall into this pit
and be burned there forever people think
you are good you're Howard hearted get
out children I exhort you to withhold
the hand of friendship to Jane Eyre
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a grand old house but it can
feel a little dreary
mister it's actually really really good
production very dark a lot creepier than
the book the book isn't that creepy but
it's well worth watching so if you're
into this sort of thing
very good production of junior with
Michael Fassbender and Mia Wasikowska
his how it's pronounced okay other
things that I like so I just got a kick
out of this Steven Naismith yesterday
was on television and he asked what has
to be one of these single dumbest
questions in the history of mankind here
we go I think we're Canelo or the
rematch particularly because the rematch
isn't gonna happen at Cinco DeMayo if
there is one right cuz I was done
fighting for the year he fights twice a
year then go to mile Mexican
Independence Day because those two dates
indicate that you owned boxing in North
America
that's why scoid always like those dates
that those are now Canelo's days he's
gonna fight them if in a rematch if it
happens I would soon think goes a mile
the bookies gonna be 36 pushing 37 at
that time well with witness witnessing
um I wonder what's the day - Cinco
DeMayo this year next year do you tell
me that I somewhere around me oh my god
when is Cinco de Maya well-spent Stephen
needs to brush up on his Spanish because
that is not a good question when when is
it when is it next year like it changes
your ears how like the Jewish calendar
actually changes the dates year to year
because we're on the lunar calendar not
the solar calendar but I'm pretty sure
Cinco de Mayo is I'm like May 5th
because it's called the 5th of May if I
if I had to hazard a guess at this and I
don't think that it was created before
the modern calendar was was created so
good for Steve a nice minute okay time
for some some quick things that I hate
okay so can we please stop comparing
things to Jews in Nazi Germany like
please unless they're actually things
that are comparable keith ellison who's
the last person in the world who should
ever invoke the holocaust considering
that he was a nation of islam backer who
was wildly anti-semitic for years and
years and years and years now he's
comparing illegal immigrants living in
the United States to Jews living in Nazi
Germany so this is not someone else's
fight this is all of our fight but some
people are in the bullseye and others of
us are not exactly the target therefore
it is our responsibility to stand up
fight and do the right thing and I'm
gonna tell you right now I want the
people who believes we should get like a
bird sanctuary and if you ask yourself
what would I do if I was a Gentile in
1941 if my Jewish papers were under
attack by them by by the Nazis
what I give them sanctuary okay I'm
pretty sure they number one keith
Ellison had been around in 1939 and Jews
had runs him for sanctuary I have
serious doubts that keith Ellison would
have provided them sanctuary himself if
you were alive in 1939 but beyond that
likening people who are living in the
United States illegally their kids going
to public schools having jobs living in
the freest most prosperous country in
the history of mankind to Jews living
under Nazi rule is just insane is just
insane and ridiculous
no purpose to it at all okay so I really
wanted to do Tucker Carlson interviewing
a witch but I'm not sure I have time to
do Tucker Carlson interview well you
know what I'm gonna do it for five
seconds so you're talkin Carlson last
night interviewed a witch because I
can't avoid this is under things I hate
because it just it gives the left fodder
that every time they take a screencap of
these things it's like Tucker Carlson on
gypsy invasion in Pennsylvania Tucker
Carlson witches take on President Trump
like I understand that there's such a
thing as ratings and I understand that
this gets them I assume but I'm not sure
that this is a valuable use of news
watching time the witches who are taking
on the president so you since you're the
only witch I've interviewed a lot of
people but I've never interviewed a
witch since your question is I have Newt
an actual ingredient I think the real
problem is
whether or not I am new is an actual
ingredient the real problem is we're
about to have some kind of big nuclear
extravaganza with North Korea the real
problem is that were punishing immigrant
children and the real problem is that
we're all right I mean there lots of
there's there's a very funny thing
online where this this canon nerdy guy
goes to what he calls the hot crazy
matrix or he talks about women who are
hot versus women who are crazy and then
where women fall along these lines and
this would be one to avoid so this is
this seems like that this seems like a
mistake Tucker I think that you can
probably get better interview subjects
than the crazy which to talk on your
show you know take it or leave it
he's got better ratings than I do he's a
news but just saying yeah I'm not sure
that this is a valuable use of time okay
so quick explanation normally we do
Bible talk today instead I'm going to
explain to you in very basic terms of
Rosh Hashanah is so Rosh Hashanah
literally means the head of the year
this is the the Jewish New Year when we
believe that the earth was created so
this is one of the cool things about
sort of the history of scientific
thought is that for thousands of years
people thought that the earth actually
was not created that it existed
eternally if you go read Aristotelian
thought Aristotle thought this so did
Plato
they thought the planets were an
internal motion and that the and that
the earth had always existed and the
Bible suggested something different so
when you read my Monte's or Aquinas
they're actually attempting to explain
how the Bible can be true and also it
can be true that the that the earth
always existed so they're trying to
rectify bad science with the Bible it
turns out that the science was bad and
the Bible was right the earth was
created so at the beginning in the
beginning God created the heavens and
the earth and but that's what we are
celebrating at Rosh Hashanah it's always
it's also the initiation of what we call
the the Days of Awe in the Jewish
calendar it's the initiation of sort of
the repentance period Jews have already
been for the month before Rosh Hashanah
beginning what we call Shuba which
literally means return returning to God
recta is recognizing the sins that we've
committed and committing not to do them
next year
this is why it's funding birth excuse
you know there are a lot of people
making New Year's resolutions for us we
already made our New Year's resolutions
back in September sometime so that's
basically what it is the
the idea is that God opens the book of
life in the book of death and decides in
the next 10 days which one you will be
written down in and say you see Jews
praying an inordinate amount and giving
charity and and performing good acts and
and trying to fulfill more Commandments
that begins tomorrow and what's cool is
that we celebrate the judgment right
it's not something that we fear on Rosh
Hashanah it's supposed to be one of the
happier days of the year we eat apples
with honey for a new year we are
supposed to celebrate God's creation of
the earth and trust in God that if we do
what we are supposed to do for him that
he is going to fulfill us spiritually
the way that he has promised to do so
that's what Russia China is all about I
will be out tomorrow I will be out
Friday I will be here all of next week
so I will see you on Monday please
that's a long weekend that's a lot of
time for you guys to really screw things
up if you could avoid doing that until I
get back so I can talk about it I would
very much appreciate it if not you're on
your own enjoy i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]